from Full House to the courthouse let's
take a look at what happened to the
olssen twins who were once the biggest
child stars on the planet plenty of kids
aspire to be actors and even more of
them dream of being famous but Mary Kate
and Ashley Olsen weren't old enough to
want anything other than a bottle or a
nap when they became incredibly famous
actors the Twins were just 6 months old
at the time they were cast in the pilot
for Full House and only 9 months old
when they began sharing the role of
Michelle Tanner Mary Kate and Ashley's
parents Dave and journey took their
daughters to an open casting where they
caught the attention of series Creator
Jeff Franklin who noticed that the ulson
babies were unusually comfortable around
strangers they got the part and to stay
on the right side of California's child
labor laws Mary Kad and Ashley took
turns working in front of the camera
long before they were aware of the fact
that they had a job Michelle Tanner
quickly became the breakout star of Full
House which reportedly caused tension
among the rest of the cast in the 1980s
and 1990s when the show aired the press
and public were often less considerate
in their treatment of child stars in a
1991 profile for the Washington Post as
an example J Matthews wrote that he and
his family were enamored with the olssen
twins despite the fact that they had
quote little acting Talent Mary Kate has
since compared her childhood experiences
to that of a performing monkey she told
Marie CLA I would never wish my
upbringing on anyone Mary Kate and
Ashley Olsen never knew life as anything
but pint-sized celebrities they grew GRE
up on the set of Full House which ran
for eight seasons from 1987 to 1995 in
fact they were barely 9 years old when
the series that had made them household
names came to an end while the
conclusion of Full House would have been
sad enough it also coincided with the
disillusion of their parents' marriage
news broke in February of 1996 that Dave
and journey Olsen who had also been
co-managing their twin daughter's
business interests had divorced some
tabloids blamed the stress of running
what had become the Olsen's
multi-million doll Empire the truth was
a story more common than extreme stage
parenting the twin's father had begun a
romantic relationship with a woman named
McKenzie who he'd worked with before he
left the mortgage industry for Hollywood
Dave married Mackenzie only a month
after his split from Journey became
public knowledge reportedly Ashley
skipped the ceremony to be by her
mother's side while Mary Kate was
present for her father's second wedding
the divorce didn't seem to drive a wedge
between the sister's relationship but it
did divide the family perhaps more so
than Dave L on Journey declined to
comment you got it dude in a 1996
conversation with Entertainment Weekly
Mary Kate Olsson reasoned that
regardless of the media Empire that
sprang up around them she and her sister
got to have normal childhood experiences
she said we go to school play with our
friends see our Pony have sleepovers the
Olson twins did attend school when
possible while their parents could have
had them tutored on set they were
enrolled at Campbell Hall in Studio City
California but the entertainment
business and the upward trajectory of of
their careers always had to take
priority over what would have been the
highlights of any other teens's High
School experience for example Mary Kate
and Ashley missed their senior prom
because they'd been booked as the hosts
of that week's episode of Saturday Night
Live which was recording the same night
their SNL appearance was to promote
their feature film New York minute and
the twins even referenced missing their
prom in their opening monologue Ashley
said we'll never know what it's like to
ride in a limo and wear fancy dresses
and have someone do our hair well it's a
huge honor to host SNL there's no
denying the twins spent their senior
year making and promoting a movie which
left little time for other regular
things like sleepovers and school dances
after they graduated from Campbell Hall
Mary Kate and Ashley Olsen planned to
attend New York University they had
already been accepted into a flexible
degree program that would allow them to
design their own curriculum while they
continued to run what was by then their
own production company dualar
Entertainment Group in preparation for
this new educational and entrepreneurial
joint Venture the twins had chosen a
private residence they intended to share
and secured nearby Office base for
dualar unfortunately their plans didn't
pan out Mary Kate and Ashley both
dropped out of NYU before they'd even
had a chance to move into their
Penthouse apartment a variety of factors
were to blame but it's possible they may
have never been very serious about their
studies there were also Whispers that
Mary Kate's Health was a factor more
problematic was the fact that Paparazzi
and the student body were so invested in
the twins day-to-day lives Olson claimed
they didn't feel safe at NYU as they
couldn't tell which of their cohorts
were selling photographs and stories to
the Press I Told You So Mary Kate and
Ashley Olsen have been the subject of
tabloid speculation going as far back as
their parents' divorce in their teen
years they became fashion and Beauty
Proto influencers and even though they'd
been churning out content through their
production company they'd become better
known as media personalities their
adoring public wanted to know what they
were up to and the intrusion only got
more intense as they approached their
18th birthdays as online media and
communication became more everpresent in
the early 2000s Mary Kad and Ashley were
subjected to a virtual wild west of
cyber treatment websites were created to
countd down to the day they turn 18 for
the explicit purpose of celebrating the
moment they'd become legal adults the
olsons were already being sexualized by
a segment of the public while these
inappropriate countdown clocks merely
upped the ante it's hard enough to be a
child whose life is on display it's much
harder to be a teenager or young adult
all of the Olsen's choices and behaviors
were scrutinized by the public and
sometimes spun into stories that simply
weren't true of all the things the Press
hounded Mary Kate and Ashley about
speculation reached a fever pitch when
it came to their weight while their
health should have remained A Private
Matter it didn't some angles suggested
rampant drug use was the reason for the
twins thin frames whereas other writeups
wondered aloud if one or both of the
Olsen weren't struggling with an eating
disorder the early odds were a pop
cultural moment in which the public was
fascinated by the downfall of
celebrities and stories about stars
entering rehab were particularly juicy
one might expect that the tabloids might
be behind the most reprehensible stuff
but respected programs like the Oprah
Winfrey Show handled the situation just
as poorly and were just as complicit in
spreading the gossip in a 2004 interview
with Oprah Mary Kate and Ashley tried to
politely dance around the topic but the
host wouldn't let it go she brought up
rumors about possible eating disorders
and even asked the girls what size they
were on National Television shortly
after the episode aired Mary Kate
entered a rehabilitation facility for
treatment of anorexia nervosa which
itself became sensationalized front-
Page News at a time when the starring
question needed help and support as we
got older we've we've we've always you
know known that no is a full
sentence that Mary Kate and Ashley Olsen
are twins in the same industry meant
that it was all but unavoidable that
they'd be compared to each other those
comparisons grew more were ill intended
as the girls matured especially during
the time Mary Kate was battling personal
issues in a public Spotlight she became
tabloid fodder while Ashley was embraced
by the Press though even that Embrace
was somewhat Insidious in 2007 Maxim
magazine ranked Ashley as the 37th
hottest woman in the world on their
annual Hot 100 list she fell to number
47 the following year and again her
sister Mary Kate was missing from the
yearly Roundup of beautiful celebrities
Ashley also began to land solo magazine
covers and as was picked up by and
contrasted in the Press Ashley was
interning for fashion designer Zack
Posen around the time Mary Kate was in
rehab even though the sisters chose to
live separately for the first time
during this phase of their lives they
remained close and supportive of each
other even as some corners of the media
tried to tell a different story Mary
Kate and Ashley Olsen didn't have any
say in their careers as child actors
that path was chosen for them by their
parents and the production team behind
Full House they did however exhibit more
agency as their career evolved once they
outgrew the kind of just for kids
projects that had been their trademark
they tried their hand at more
broad-based and familyfriendly fair with
2004's New York minute alas the horribly
reviewed movie would be the last time
that twins would share the screen
together as well as the last time they'd
headline a film or TV series Ashley had
an unnamed role in the largely forgotten
2008 comedy The Jerk Theory and then
largely called it quits on her acting
career to focus on her passion for
fashion Mary Kate lasted a while longer
she appeared in Factory girl the
wackness and beastly and she had an
eight episode run on the Showtime series
Weeds their younger sibling Elizabeth
olon has gone on to have the Superior
Body of work starring as Wanda maximoff
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
receiving a claim for her performances
in films like Martha Marcy May marleene
and his three daughters the Olsen twins
briefly flirted with the idea of
returning to the role that put them on
the map when Full House was set to
reboot as Fuller house but the pair
ultimately chose to pass on the
opportunity citing their many years away
from the camera and their thriving
design business as justification well
Michelle sends her love but she's busy
in New York running her fashion
Empire in Hollywood relationships are
infamously difficult to sustain both
Olsen twins have found that to hold true
Ashley has dated notable men from the
worlds of entertainment and sports her
first bow was Columbia University
quarterback Matt Kaplan followed by club
owner Scott sartiano she was on again
off again with actor Jared and was
momentarily tied to cyclist Lance
Armstrong she and actor Justin bartha
dated for 3 years as he was starring in
The Hangover but the couple ended their
relationship in 2011 in addition Dax
Shephard claims to have gone out with
her as well Ashley met her husband Louie
Eisner earlier but didn't recognize him
as a love match until 2017 the couple
quietly married in 2022 and welcomed
their first child in 2023 as in other
areas of their lives Mary Kate's
romantic experiences have been more
tabloid worthy and tragic she was
rumored to have been dating actor Heath
Ledger after his breakup with actor and
mother of his child Michelle Williams
when Ledger died of an overdose in 2008
the woman who found the body contacted
Mary Kate first Mary Kate has repeatedly
declined to comment about leder's death
she'd later marry French banker and
brother of the former French president
Olivier sarosi who was nearly 20 years
her senior they divorced in 2020 when he
invited his ex-wife to move in with them
during the pandemic Mary Kate and Ashley
Olsson will always be known for their
portrayal of Michelle Tanner but these
days the success of their fashion Empire
has far outpaced that of their once
Mighty production company when it comes
to their clothing brands the Olsens have
been commended for signing on a pledge
to guarantee their Factory workers
maternity leave but they got themselves
into hot water over at dualar
entertainment in 2015 40 former and
present interns sued the Olson and their
company for wage theft in a class action
lawsuit they claimed that even though
they'd been hired as interns they were
putting in upwards of 50 hours a week
and doing the same tasks as paid
employees the case was settled out of
court in 2017 and Mary Kaden Ashley were
forced to cough up $140,000 in back pay
to be divided amongst the 185
[Music]
interns